ready for a story about superheroes more
TV superheroes just what the world needs
be honest have you hung yourself yet
or what if I told you this was actually
a story about super zeroes losers
achingly pathetic metahuman goose eggs
how about it ready to feel better about
your own miserable lives for the next
hour or so follow me
our story begins as such stories do with
a visit to a Nazi I'm sorry cobbler mr.
Morden
yes yes you must be served on Fuhrer von
phul penis sorry
and your party knows who the village
cobbler
[Music]
Vaughn Fuchs was renowned for his
theoretical experimentation offering
certain enhancements for a price a price
mr. Morden was more than willing to pay
oh I forgot mr. Morden
that's me well it was me a third-rate
bad guy a nameless entman
a real nobody I forked over a king's
ransom to that demented genius and if I
knew what he had planned for me
I would have paid double can you hear me
mr. Morden yes are you ready mr. Morden
repeat after me please
the mine is again
again
oh please touch me do you remember what
it felt like to be normal
I'm working with some fascinating people
each one of them is just bursting with
potential I'm using every person I save
is me fulfilling a pledge to my mom that
she'll never get to hear father and I
already discussed it trying to make her
proud knowing I'm the reason she's not
around to see this is molten ever been
mr. Morden sensor ah nobody I've been my
those freaks of yours for quite some
time are we really the best people to
hunt a supervillain hell no you're all
at my mercy
no matter how hard I hit where I had
what I had I can't feel pain
you're as afraid as the rest of us
[Music]
you're kidding me
this is what the world looks like when
we try to live in it
we don't have to get involved especially
if we make things worse I want to go
home we can do that I don't even know
what to hope for I'm powerless I have no
clue how to fix this
Edith this mission you're on is your
mission I'm a criminal we bust and the
person we save is us chief said his
enemies were coming for him don't worry
we got this
[Music]
what do you want from me
Oh
don't you get it they are quite doomed
everybody is Charlie so we got to talk
about Doom Patrol episode 1 this is the
opening scene and they're just a little
bit from the trailer giving you a sense
for the rest of the series it is by a
design meant to be the weirdest of DC
Comics series because it's based on the
Grant Morrison run if you've ever read a
Grant Morrison comic book you know
exactly what that means
so we'll do a new round of that DC
streaming service giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your favorite Doom Patrol moment
on the video the opening scene totally
sets the tone and works in a way that
the Titans pilot episode just didn't
quite come together because it's very
serious material like it's a dark gritty
series but none of the characters take
themselves seriously in alan tudyk mr.
nobody character as the narrator sort of
calls them on their [ __ ] in Deadpool
style breaks the fourth wall calling
[ __ ] on all the writers all the
producers for making a terrible series
and calling out critics for prematurely
hating the series before they seen it
that was probably one of the funniest
fourth wall breaks during the episode
lovely Rita queen of fifty cinema some
critics called her the poor man's
Deborah Kerr some critics called her the
rich man's yevette Vickers critics what
do they know they're gonna hate this
show I'm so happy that they got alan
tudyk to be the villain for this as this
omniscient narrator I believe that he
does this for all the episodes where he
does the voiceovers but he also like in
this really weird way within episodes
also refers to himself as the narrator
so just in general the series itself
feels like it's put together much better
than Titans was put together initially
and if you're wondering where Beast Boy
is because this is a spin-off of the
Titans series because you saw the same
characters during Titans episode for
Doom Patrol but you met them in a
slightly different way and they don't
really address Beast Boy during the
episode so my guess is is that when
they're doing all those montages and the
time jumps as you're learning about
robot man's backstory that's when Beast
Boy comes and goes but maybe later in
the season we'll see him guest star or
pop up at some point because this is all
happening during present day like it
says 2019 when they're playing with the
Train said so that's after the events of
the Titans episode which was during 2018
so very clearly they'll find some way to
loop this in I don't know how many
Titans actors are actually gonna cross
over to this but I think the idea is is
because cyborg is a classic Teen Titans
character eventually cyborg will
crossover with that series but for now
it just seems like season 1 Doom Patrol
he's gonna be with this team of
characters the trailer footage has
scenes from much later in the series so
you learn a little bit about cyborgs
backstory across the first couple of
episodes and it's a little bit different
from Justice League cyborg or the comic
book version of the character they
haven't referenced anything about a
mother box or a father box like Young
Justice season 3 just did a version of
cyborg we got the origin story it was a
father box instead of a mother box that
gave him his powers but we haven't quite
got to the point on Doom Patrol where
they've completely explained that but
really cool Easter Egg the person that's
playing Silas stone his father on Doom
Patrol is actually Martian Manhunter
from Smallville so if you're a big
Smallville fan you'll recognize him
immediately like hey wait a minute
but he's not a huge character in the
first couple of episodes cyborg is a bit
of a slow burn but the cool thing about
him though is that he also brings in a
lot of Justice League Canon - he
references a lot of Justice League
things that are going on in present day
during this Doom Patrol Titans universe
so you always kind of wonder what's
going on with this version of Justice
League because we know that Batman
exists we know that Wonder Woman exists
and we know the Superman exists now
because we have Superboy Conner Kent on
Titans but I don't think it's a spoiler
to say that cyborg does reference a
version of Barry Allen flash and it's
not Grant Gustin and it's not as
Remillard so if you ever wondered if
there's going to be a speedster on
Titans eventually in a future season I
think they have a good chance that they
do that because if you have a version of
Barry Allen the flash within the
universe then there's gonna be versions
of other speedsters too like Bart Allen
or even Wally West so this should
explain why is separate from the CW DC
TV universe and why they're probably not
going to be involved with crisis on
Infinite Earths this year I know that's
a big question because it's such a big
comic book event you feel like everybody
should be involved with it I think a lot
of the things that Doom Patrol has going
for it as a TV show though is that it's
really well written it's like legends of
tomorrow in the DC TV universe it's a
bunch of characters that you might not
necessarily care about as much as say
the other bigger a list characters but
it just put together very well and it
doesn't treat itself too seriously like
they're free to make fun of themselves
the characters spend the entire episode
taking shots at each other and watch now
here comes hammerhead this one's kind of
an [ __ ] except Jane's not here you
see little [ __ ] she's in a mood heard
you the first time are you a raving
douche
hello hammerhead good to see you [ __ ]
off and die Rita
crazy Jane is probably one of my
favorite characters from the series I'm
still kind of warming up to cyborg and
some of the other characters like Rita
Farr Brendan Fraser is amazing this is
probably one of the greatest comeback
stories ever for him especially the way
they intro him in this series as the
race car driver so if you're not a big
comic book reader for the most part all
the stuff they're doing is from the
Grant Morrison Doom Patrol run so you
can go read that if you want but they're
being pretty authentic to those origins
with a couple twists because obviously
that was taking place a long time ago
and this is taking place in 2019 but the
other really cool behind the scenes
Easter Egg is that the person that
created this show Jeremy Carver also
created Supernatural which is now
entering its billionth season but let me
know in the comments what you guys think
about all the characters or if you have
any specific requests for bonus videos I
have no idea what happens later in the
series I've only seen the first couple
of episodes and it does get a little bit
better the pilot is always a little bit
raw compared to the rest of the season
Titans is probably the best example of a
show that gets better with each episode
like you start out and you're like oh
you know I love Nightwing and I love
some of these other Titans characters
but I just don't know how I feel about
this series then going into season 2 it
just sounds much more exciting because
we have all this Connor can Superboy the
team is coming together we have Donna
Troy Wonder Girl on the team and we have
Deathstroke coming in with Grant Wilson
so it's just gonna be really cool to see
what they do with that show but while
you wait for everything click here for
my Titans season 2 teaser video and that
post-credit scene with Superboy and
click here to watch Ben Affleck explain
why he quit being Batman before his
contract was up thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight